so Leute ich bin auch zur Abwechslung mal da
Dienstag Abend
Boomer müde
es ist schon spät
hä so schlimm ist es doch nicht
aber naja fast 20 Uhr ist nicht mal lange hin
moin
ich muss ich muss mal bisschen bisschen ordentliche Musik anmachen, dass ich wach werde wieder
eine eine Runde Headbanging
ich mach gleich ein bisschen was hintergrund gedudelt täglicheres an
oh
mein
key Nummer zwei PR
Key Nummer zwei nee
Key Nummer zwei
Key Numer Zwei
Key Nummer Zwei
Key Number Zwei
Key Nummer Drei
Key Nummer Vier
Es schwankt halt
mal tut's bisschen weh mal nicht
es ist halt nervig. Wobei witzigerweise
nachts tut mir der Zahn nicht weh
tagsüber schon, normalweise ist es umgedreht
tagsüber merkt man es nachts nicht so richtig
keine Ahnung
Zahnarzt mein, es könnte auch Zahnfleisch sein
weil das wohl ein bisschen entzückend aussieht
aber weiß nicht, so lange jetzt
ach, keine Ahnung
aber ich
ja, aber ich wollte euch nochmal was anderes zeigen
also ich war letzte Woche schonmal
im Zahnarzt, ich habe nächste Woche
und ohne scheiss Roll ich sag euch
ich hab da langsam kein Bock mehr drauf
wenn das bis nächste Woche Montag nicht weg ist
dann frag ich den Zahnarzt
was man da am besten machen kann
und selbst wenn er sagt
Zahn weg
und Prothese rein
oder wie man das nennt
lass ich das machen, juchke mich nicht
selbst wenn's 2000 Euro kostet, es ist mir egal
Hauptsache ich hab nicht mehr
alle Furzlangen oben links
implantat heißt das
ja
du meinst zum Geldsparen
so arm bin ich nicht, kann ich mir schon leisten
ordentliche Behandlung
also ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass er sagt zahn raus
ich gehe davon aus dass er sagt
müssen wir nochmal auffüllen
gucken ob Wurzelspitze, keine Ahnung
eigentlich hab ich keinen Bock drauf
ich find's lieber, der macht den zahn raus und ne plantat rein
und dann ist endgültig Ruhe
und der kram funktioniert auch wunderbar
also es gibt so ein paar Sachen
dafür lohnt sich das Geld auszugeben
das sind unter anderem gescheit zahnersatz
und generell so
Gesundheits und Krankheitssachen
dafür lohnt sich einfach Geldauszugeben
du hast nix davon paar Euro zu sparen
und scheiße behandelt zu werden
in Form von ärztlicher Behandlung
ja andere Behandlung auch
das lohnt sich da einfach mal Geldauszugeben
was
Das Auto
ist kaputt gegangen?
Oh das aber schlecht
also beim Fiat geht es noch gut?
Haben wir hier schon drüber gesprochen?
Nama
Der Kampffeld wird in ein ganz neues Feld wiederkomme
die labern alle
immerrum wenn Andrew Wilson das sagt
das kann d ja nur gutempfehlen
der ist nicht so verantwortlich
dass überhaupt so gewesen ist
ob noch mehr
EA Steuerung da was bringt
der Fehler von 2042 liegt sicherlich nicht nur an EA
aber das garantiert einen großen Anteil dran gehabt
aber das ist ja aktuell
ziemlich nichts sagend
das ist so, wir haben halt mal was gesagt
und jetzt ist gut
das ist halt echt viel Bullshit Gelaber
MicrosoftOffice.zip
wie, who is? Habe ich nicht installiert?
diese Domain kann ja nur
komplett legale
100% legit
legit Absichten haben
wenn man Sie so in das Domain aufzeichnet oder?
Der Scam ging natürlich sofort los
guckt es euch an
Microsoftoffice.zip
gefakter Microsoft Login
um Account Daten abzugreifen
Also was für eine bescheuerte Idee von Google
überhaupt so eine Top Level Domain zu machen
ich meine was denn als Nächstes
Top Level Domain ..
....
...
Was fällt Ihnen denn als Nächstes noch ein?
Also .zip ist wirklich eine
Mega Bescheuerte Idee gewesen
Das...
Top Level Domain irgendwie
zu vermarkten
Wie war das eigentlich mit den .COM Dateien
Ich glaube
..die Probleme gab es da theoretisch schon
aber ich glaube das hat damals nicht so viel ausgenutzt
zumal ja auch com Dateien
äußerst selten verschickt werden
und .zip Dateien relativ häufig
nur rein weil es die Dateiendung
gibt ist er nicht
problematisch, Problematisch ist ja z.B
weil du jetzt faken kannst so nach dem Motto
ich schicke dir jetzt Microsoft
in Wirklichkeit ist es eigentlich
und wir versuchen
deine Accountcredentials abzugraben
aber das ist ja auch egal
,zip ist ja nur das du
Dateinamen faken kannst
und als Link sieht das aus
für Unwissende
mit einer Datei
die angehängt war
aber in Wirklichkeit ist das halt so eine fake Microsoft-Seite
bestimmt
bestimmt, Beiss
und Wahrscheinlich gibts auch Porn.zip
und solche Sachen
fall victim
to this
invasion
so
ex special forces
typischer tag
die abys
weil es eine typische amerikanische schicht, und
bei uns, stelle dir mal vor, bei uns, du machst die Tür auf,
da läuft dann einer vor der Tür rum,
rennt rum, und och erst mal
abschießt. das ist ja so eine typische
amerikanische Situation, ja?
das ist so eine typische amerikanische Situation,
die gibt es wahrscheinlich nirgendwo sonst, auf der
Welt.
immer mit
geladener Waffe, die Tür aufmachen, ja?
also
der muss da halt sein Property
defenden!
und ich meine,
es gibt auch welche, die stehen da gleich mit der Shotgun
oder so rum. das war
wirklich so eine typische Amerikaner-Moment.
ich weiß übrigens auch nicht,
warum mir dieses Video
hier, warum mir das empfohlen wurde,
aber
aus irgendwelchen Gründen
war Youtube der Meinung,
ich will
Home-Defense-Technik
in Amerikanern
lernen.
Aber das ist wirklich
eines der grunnelligsten Videos, die ich je gesehen
habe.
Ah guck mal, ich mach die Tür auf, ah da läuft einer,
Bäm! erst mal erschießen.
Leiste Taktik.
Ähm...
Alles allererst,
male ich weiter.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfracht,
ah, hier halte ich das Video auf.
Das ist jetzt aber,
sehr verwirrend,
weil eigentlich hab ich hier die Videos auf und
die Musik habe ich hier auf, das heißt,
wenn ich das jetzt mische, dann
blicke ich, gar nicht mehr, durch.
Vielleicht ist das
kombinarisch, das kann sein, also keine Ahnung warum
mir google das heute Morgen empfohlen hat.
Sowas zum Beispiel..
Plätschler
ich glaube, das können wir schlecht nachvollziehen
ja also eines der Hauptargumente, die ich immer von Amis höre
und ich kann das aus ihrer Sicht durchaus nachvollziehen ist
Ich brauch eine Pistole, weil was mache ich, wenn mich einer überfällt mit einer Pistole
So und mit dem Argument kriegst beiden Amis eigentlich immer so die Kurve und sagst
Ja ok, dann brauche ich eine Pistole
Am Besten wäre natürlich, wenn gar keiner standardmäßig eine Pistole dabei hat
Ja richtig, genau, genau das meine ich ja
Ja, jaja genau
Es ist, dass da.. ich glaube da ist auch schwierig, was du als Außenstehender dagegen zu sagen
Ich glaube wir können das gar nicht richtig nachvollziehen
Genau, es ist, also dass ist, dass ist, ..das ist die Ami Logik
Wenn du überfallen wirst von einem mit einer Pistole
Ist das beste, wenn du selbst eine Pistole dabei hast
Was ja nicht unbedingt einer gewissen
Wie soll ich sagen.. so einer gewissen Logik entbehrt
Was aber halt, so irgendwo zu einer Art Wettrüsten sorgt, ja
So nach dem Wort, ich geh garnich mehr ohne Pistole raus
Nein, nein, du hast was vergessen
Sicherheit ist egal
Freedom
Muss es sein
Hell yeah! Freedom
Und natürlich alle anderen auch
Aber was sollen sie machen, ich mein das ist halt ihr Ding
Das ist halt so das Ami Ding
Kann ich mir vorstellen
Nicht vergessen Leute, Donnerstag ist Feiertag
Ey ich mein wenn du an Schulen schon irgendwelche Metalldetektoren brauchst
Vodafone entlässt paar tausend Leute, das habe ich gelesen
Vodafone entlässt aber wohl
in Deutschland... Ficks ihm nicht mehr im Kopf
Ich glaub die entlassen irgendwie tausend dreihundert Leute
Stellen aber vierehundert neue Leute ein
Und die entlassen hauptsächlich Leute im in...
so im Mittleren Management, Verwaltung und solche Geschichten
und was Support und Technik angeht scheinen die well neue Leute einzustellen
Also insofern eigentlich eine begrüssenswerte Entscheidung
weniger Bullshit-Schwätzer und mehr Technikleute einzustellen
Was ja für ein Internetprovider
der wohl auch Probleme mit seinem Service und Probleme mit seiner Technik hat
Keine allzu schlechte Entscheidung ist
Wir können mal kurz gucken ob ich...
Fraser hat da irgendeinen Artikel dazu
Unsere Leistung war nicht gut genug
Jawoll
Was sagen sie?
Ähm, ich weiß gar nicht wo es steht, wie viele Leute...
Hier, hier genau, 1300 Jobs
So, Moment
Jo, also genau, die äh schmeißend 1300 Leute raus
und stellen 400 neue ein
und sie stellen hauptsächlich neue Leute ein
im Bereich
auf Service und Technik
Also, finde ich durchaus nachvollziehbar
dass man sagt, bisschen weniger
Gemiete, bisschen weniger
ähm
management
... müssen bisschen weniger Blödsinn
gelaber, sondern bisschen mehr Service und Technik
Was durchaus nach nem Plan klingt
für nen Provider, der es sonst nicht auf die Reihe kriegt
Moin, Emko
...
....
..
...